[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact in 1980
Craig Richard kool-aid was convicted for
killing an ex-girlfriend and her son in
Los Angeles Koli insisted he was
innocent but that was all before DNA
evidence could be analyzed after four
decades of Appeals a friend and retired
police officer was eventually able to
persuade the court to examine the DNA
evidence as a result in 2017 after
spending 39 years in prison Koli was
found innocent of the double murder and
pardoned by Governor Jerry Brown of
California in addition he will now
receive a 21 million dollar settlement
from the city of Simi Valley for a
wrongful imprisonment from discouraged
prisoner to millionaire but how sad to
have all of that money and most of your
life behind you
you know Jesus addresses this question
in the Bible stay with his friends were
going to learn more on this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 72 97 with
your Bible questions now we give out
another number during the program for
our prayer line and for free resources
that we always make available during
this broadcast
we're also streaming if you're online
you can watch what's happening here in
the studio just go to the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page or the amazing facts
Facebook page and my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug let's
start with prayer dear father thank you
that we can open your word and study
together and we do ask your blessing
upon this program we ask Lord that your
spirit to guide our hearts our minds as
we search the Scriptures for for answers
we know you have the answer to life's
important questions we ask a blessing
and those who are hearing this program
in Jesus name Amen
amen pastor you opened the program are
talking about in Frank
mmm interesting situation you have a man
who gets awarded what 21 million dollars
but at what cost 39 years of freedom I
wonder if you would offer someone a
large sum of money
20 million but say there's a catch
you're gonna have to be in prison for 40
years before you're able to access that
money how many would actually
take you up on the offer you might have
some but it seems a high price to pay I
don't think there'd be too many that
would gamble they would live 40 years
and have any time left to really enjoy
that 20 million dollars but you know God
is offering us something much better
he's saying look if you will commit to
me this life if you'll lay down your
life take up your cross and follow me I
will give you 20 gazillion dollars in
eternity I mean you think about what
we're gonna have in the way of wealth
and heaven and how long we're gonna live
Paul says in Romans 8:18 for I consider
that the sufferings of this present life
are not worthy to be compared with the
glory that will be revealed in us and
yet so many people trade the eternal
wealth for a little bit of time in this
life that's why Jesus said what profit
is it to a man if he gains the whole
world and he loses his own soul or what
will a man give in exchange for his soul
you know the real riches that we can
have there's many people in prison
they're spiritually rich because they
have the Lord but if you're on the
outside and you've got a bank full of
money and you don't have the Lord you're
you're a slave in your poor so the real
riches are the riches of knowing the
Lord of freedom and knowing you have
everlasting life
we have a special offer for you tonight
that talks about that that I think
you'll find very encouraging and it's
free so why wouldn't you want it we have
a book called the riches of His grace
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks again the book
is called the riches of His grace and
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven that is a resource phone line and
as for the book called the riches of His
grace again the number is 883 five six
seven four seven and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here in the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven good time if you have a Bible
question give us a call 800 four six 372
97 we're gonna got our first caller this
evening we have Bill listening in
Illinois bill welcome to the program Oh
dr. John how are you hi thanks for
calling um I kinda have a worship
question okay I most the time I before I
give sleep
a revival for a while and then I hit her
and got him to have it oh thank the
night fathers tonight Jesus can I Holy
Spirit tonight angels I love you all
tonight is that okay
I don't know why it wouldn't be okay
they all exist they all hear you and now
yeah I wouldn't say that all the angels
in the world hear you but probably your
guardian angels hear it there's nowhere
in the Bible where we're commanded to
communicate with the Angels other than
when angels actually appeared to men
then you know they communicated but I
don't see anywhere where we're directed
to do it but I don't see any harm in it
yeah any thoughts on that pastor Ross
well I'm just thinking in the Bible
typically prayer is directed to God the
Father and you have a Holy Spirit you
can ask for the Holy Spirit you can ask
for guidance from the Holy Spirit your
prayers go up in the name of Jesus so
you address the Sun and we do have
examples in the Bible where people
prayed to the Father but Stephen pray to
Christ and of course when Jesus on the
earth the disciples had a very real
personal relationship with Jesus and I'm
sure that didn't end the moment Jesus
went to heaven
matter of fact it even grew stronger as
Jesus said the comfortable coming and
even reveal more so I think having a
meaningful prayer with the father and
the son praying for the gift of the Holy
Spirit
definitely fits in the Bible you know
actually I thought well there is one
other place where you could say a person
prayed to Jesus it's the last words in
the Bible where John says even so come
Lord Jesus that's right it's an appeal
something of a prayer to Christ but no I
don't see anything wrong with that bill
yeah it's it's just something between
you and the Lord a little personally
goodnight
yeah the doing it for a while completely
I don't know it seems like something
Funky's nagging at me that maybe I
shouldn't well now if the Bible says if
anything is not of faith it's sin so you
know if you feel uncomfortable about it
then you might want to hold back until
you feel convicted or you find scripture
that
gives you more guidance but I don't see
I don't personally see anything wrong
with saying good night Lord or Lord keep
me through the night and just commit
yourself to him well I'll talk to you in
the first thing in the morning Lord you
know I don't think God usually I want to
say good morning you know yeah I know a
theology professor the first thing he
did every morning is he reached his hand
up in the air and he said Lord take my
hand through this day good morning and
so it was very real to him and I don't
see any harm in that
alright he thanks appreciate your
question and that does open up another
phone line if you want to call in with
your Bible question once again the
number is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven of course a free phone call
you know we also have a book dealing
with the subject of Prayer called teach
us to pray and we can send this to
anyone wanting to learn more about
prayer the number is 883 five six seven
four seven that is the resource phone
line and as for the book on prayer it's
called teach us to pray we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
we have Henry listening from Georgia
Henry welcome to the program oh thank
you and thank you for your great work
pastors I had a question here I know we
studied line by line preset by precept
here little there little and I had a
question about Luke 15 26 If any man
come to me and hate not his father and
mother and wife and children and
brethren and sisters yay it is all life
also he cannot be my disciple I
understand the context here but maybe
somebody would be unclear about that
with you would you expand on that please
well obviously the Lord does not want us
you know we're in one place that says
honor your father and mother and then
Jesus said unless you hate you think
well which is it Lord do you want me to
honor them you want me to hate them I
think Christ you read the context of
what he's saying around that he says if
you do not bear your cross and come
after me all through the Gospel of Luke
he's talking about that you need to seek
first God's kingdom he's really saying
you can't make
a father mother even your wife and
children brothers and sisters you cannot
put them before me you must know when he
says heat it doesn't mean you go it's
not a proactive hate it's sort of a
passive a despising meaning that you put
them as inferior to the primary love or
they're secondary to the primary love
for God you know in the previous chapter
just to get well it's the same chapter
it's actually in verse you can read in
verse 18 Jesus told a parable about a
feast that was prepared and then
invitations were sent out and those who
were invited made excuses as to why they
couldn't come and the one said I have
bought a piece of ground and I cannot
come another one says I've bought five
yoke of Arc's and the other one said
well I've just got married I cannot come
and they all they made all these excuses
immediately following that parable Jesus
then says if anyone comes to me and does
not hate his father his mother his wife
his children brothers so on yeah even
his own life he cannot be my disciple in
other words Jesus is contrasting the
excuses that were made by those who
invited ances if you want to be a
follower you need to recognize I need to
be first above your property above your
possessions even above family relations
yeah foes shall be those of your own
household and in my sister I'm working
I'm working the only law and the
testimony a path right now so I'm
sensing some of that even more so lately
you know so I would appreciate your
thoughts and prayers on that part too
yeah absolutely
you know there is a place in in Genesis
chapter 29 it talks about where Jacob
married Rachel and Leah he never really
wanted to marry Leah he wanted to worry
marry Rachel and says in verse 30 that
he loved Rachel more than Leah and the
commentator here is basically saying and
then you go to verse 31 and when the
Lord saw that leah was hated that just
means loved less matter of fact the
closing words of Jacob's life he tells
Joseph bury me with Leah see they didn't
say burying me was Rachel so it just
he loved Rachel more and then it the
next verse that says leah was hated
while he he took good care of him both
he didn't hate her
it's just meaning she was love less I
see okay and that by the way once again
that's Genesis 29 verse 30 and 31 that's
probably the best way to understand
those verses you've got to love father
mother sister brother husband wife
children less than me or you're not
worthy of me yeah I think the problem is
some situations and family they just you
know they don't look into the light you
know God's Word is light and compare
Scripture with Scripture that's right
well thank you Henri god bless and we'll
remember to keep you in our prayers our
next quarter that we have is II Frank
listening from New York you Frank
welcome to the program yes good evening
pastor Doug and pastor Ross thank you
for taking my phone call this evening my
question for both of you gentlemen is
something that I've been pondering for
years and years is in regards to what a
person receives salvation once they
receive salvation yeah can they help
others also think about obtaining
salvation as well giving them the hope
that they can actually receive salvation
because I have used always the scripture
of the parting of the Red Sea by Moses
to help keep many individuals in my life
to understand what God can be like is
that fair enough to teach people
individuals children elderly that
salvation comes through faith alone well
yeah certainly the parting of the Red
Sea is a great example of how God saves
us from the slavery of Egypt and so it
you can use that as an illustration of
salvation furthermore you know as soon
as you come to the Lord you don't have
to wait until you've been through
seminary and have a list of degrees
anybody who comes to the Lord Christ
calls them then to make disciples we
share our testimony and even in
Revelation it says we overcome by the
blood of the Lamb on the word of our
testimony we should always be able to be
ready to share with others what God has
done for us and you know pass on the
salvation matter of fact it's hard to
keep Christianity unless you
give it away as you share it it gets
stronger does that make sense yes well
thank you so much he Frank you good to
hear from you again and trust that the
answer helped a little bit does your
heart burns for a better purpose do you
yearn to do more with your faith do you
desire to be a powerful witness a blaze
for Jesus Christ where do you start
make your first step at eff go the
amazing fact center of evangelism here
at Avco I've learned so many things in
my spiritual growth has just skyrocketed
fqo has distilled fifty years of amazing
facts evangelistic expertise into a
dynamic professional and educational
experience that transforms the nervous
Christian into a prepared and bold
witness Affco is really about learning
while doing it's a one-of-a-kind
experience for those who are serious
about entering gospel ministry and those
who simply want to make an impact in
their local churches and communities go
to ask org today and explore this
life-changing program Affco equipping
soul-winners setting the world ablaze
for god and explore that we have is the
man been listening from let's see I
think it's New England somewhere Amanda
or Nebraska oh hello hi welcome to the
program hi Amanda oh hi Greene I just
had a question there was a conversation
about anyone being in heaven and someone
said that Elijah cannot be in heaven now
because of John 3:13 and I was just
wondering what your thoughts are on that
yeah I don't think in John 3:13 when
Jesus says no one has ascended to heaven
he's not making the emphasis on just no
one going up to heaven because Christ
Elijah had already gone to heaven
Enoch had gone to heaven and Moses had
gone to heaven proof of that is Moses
and Elijah come back down in Mark
chapter 9 they talk with Jesus Christ is
saying no one has come up gone up to
heaven and come back from the Father
so Jesus he died he ascended he come
back he came back down so Christ really
he was Christ as the connecting link
between heaven and earth it's not saying
that no one had ascended okay all right
I just wasn't quite sure how to respond
to that I don't know if that makes sense
yeah
well and keep in mind the Bible's pretty
clear it's appointed unto man once to
die and then the judgment right that's
the scripture I'm quoting okay
but we know there's a couple of
exceptions of people who didn't die
Enoch and Elijah they're very very very
remote exceptions when you think about
all the people that have lived so when
God makes a blanket statement it's
appointed unto man wants to die and then
the judgment he supplies speaking about
the human race at large he's not talking
about the very rare exception
Jesus likewise is not talking about the
very rare exception of Elijah who went
to heaven and a fiery chariot I don't
know anyone else that did that or is he
talking about
Enoch who walk with God and God took him
so when Christ says no man has ascended
to heaven you could even say generally
speaking crisis you know he's he's
saying that people don't die and go
right to heaven come back down to earth
though there were a couple of rare
exceptions to that okay thank you yeah
yeah wondering how someone can get that
but the penny wouldn't be in heaven
because it clearly says what they were
so I decided to turn Lots on that you
know I have a and I've got a book I'll
send you that talks about Moses and
Elijah and they're going to have and how
they got there and that may be helpful
it's called the two witnesses or the
glorious mount and we'll send you a free
copy of that if you just call the number
Pastor Ross is going to give you the
number to call is 800 eight three five
six seven four seven and again you can
ask for the book called the glorious
mount on the two witnesses Moses in the
ijen I think you'll find it very
interesting one more time that number is
885 six seven four seven and the phone
line here to the studio with your Bible
question is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven and our next caller that we
have is Clinton listening from
California Clinton welcome to the
program greetings brothers how are you
doing well appreciate your call and your
question tonight well okay I'm a bit
confused and please forgive my ignorance
you know I hear a lot of people say just
speaking coming of Christ and if I'm not
mistaken gaunt groom survival didn't
didn't Jesus come down to visit Abraham
prior to his birth with Joseph and Mary
and then
he also come down after is his
resurrection to visit I think meri and
then also the apostle or did the visit
Peter and asking for something to eat so
I'm a bit confused on the second coming
if he's been bouncing back and forth so
many times if you elaborate on that
please sure that's a great question
because you're technically you're right
Jesus not only appeared to Moses in the
burning bush he probably is the one who
appeared to Joshua when he said take his
shoes off your feet this is holy ground
you're not supposed to worship another
person he's certainly the one who
appeared to Abraham and maybe even
others in the Old Testament Jacob
wrestled with an angel and then he said
I've seen God some wonder did he
wrestled with Christ you know we don't
know the answer to all the what they
call them Chris Stephanie's the times
when Christ prior to his first coming we
see there we go again first coming prior
to his coming as a sacrifice you know
how many times was that that he
intervened in human affairs so when we
say first coming we're talking about the
first general visible coming for all
people everyone alive in Israel could
see Jesus walking he was incarnate
second coming he's coming again for
every eye will see him so these are
talking about you know it's the
universal coming of the Lord
technically though you know if you
wanted you could start counting up all
the different appearances and and try
and pick a number from there I think
also and talks about the first coming in
the second coming that's referring to
when Christ came and actually dwelt with
man you can read him first John where it
says he tabernacled with us meaning he
to cover himself flesh and blood he
became one with the human race and of
course at the second coming in John
chapter 14 says we shall come in the
clouds of glory we shall be caught up to
meet him in the air thus we shall always
be with the Lord
so the first coming but didn't he did he
come down with with into the Peter and
asking for subtlety
yeah well Jesus met at the sea and he
talked to several disciples and he did
ask him he said children do you have any
food and he met in the upper room that
was all still part of his first coming
so that all happened in you know the
lifetime it within three and a half
years of his
his public ministry you're right he did
after the resurrection he ascended to
heaven he came back down he appeared in
the upper room
he appeared on the road to Emmaus he
appeared at the sea and I think he
appeared on the Mount of Olives
so that's and maybe even more than that
but he he appeared several times after
his resurrection ok ok well thank you
very much brother
I appreciate you did you know we got a
book on the second coming that we'll be
happy to send you it's got a lot of
scriptures dealing with a subject I
would love it I would love it alright
and it's called the ultimate deliverance
and the number to call if you'd like is
that rescue from above sorry ultimate to
live well let me check we're gonna give
you book this whole title deliverance
yes yes the number to call there if
you'd like to receive that book clinton
leaves eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and of course not
just for clinton about anyone wanting to
learn more about this call and ask for
this study guide called the ultimate
deliverance all about the second coming
of christ that's eight hundred eighty
three five six seven four seven next for
today we have is let's see we've got
let's go to Moses in Hayward California
Moses welcome to the program and thank
you for taking my call hello pastor doc
alright thank you for calling you know
I'm just gonna I'll try to be as brief
as I can right my mother brought me to
the church when I was little and I can
eat to this country when I was like 15
years old now now I'm 35 the question is
they told me that I was then I can ask a
question but I decided to switch to
another question I'm not gonna mention
any any denomination or anything in
particular but for me is very important
to ask this question okay a third day
Adventist but I was lucky as I was doing
why was the reason jesus told his
disciples
let'em or somebody else I was speaking
of our God to let him do it even if he
wasn't close to the Paschal disciple
yeah I think I know you're talking about
when Peter and I think it may have been
Peter and James came to Jesus and said
there was somebody else that it was
casting out Devils in your name and we
told him to stop and Jesus said do not
forbid him because if he is not
no man can speak good of the Son of Man
and be against me and so is that the
verse you're talking about I think oh
yeah okay I think pastor Ross is looking
that up you know Jesus said there's
other sheep I have and this is John
chapter 10 he said there's other sheep I
have that are not of this fold them all
so I must call they'll be one fold and
one Shepherd there were people who
believed in Jesus that maybe did not
walk were the twelve disciples and they
may not have sat under the daily
teaching of Christ but they believed he
was the Messiah and they were teaching
others they heard the disciples were out
casting out Devils in Jesus name and
they were doing it you know you have in
the New Testament the example of
Apollo's Apollo's was preaching mightily
the things of God but he didn't
understand everything and Aquila and
Priscilla took him aside and they helped
expand his understanding
you got the verse yeah it's mark chapter
9 verse 39 why don't you read that it
says when John answered him saying
teacher we saw someone who does not
follow us casting out demons in your
name and we forbade him because he does
not follow us jesus said do not forbid
him for no one who works a miracle in my
name can soon afterwards speak evil of
me yeah Christ is saying he obviously is
on our side and I think we need to be
very careful as Christians and if you're
members of a particular church you've
got to be guarded against saying well
because someone is not part of my church
or my denomination that God can't work
through them I think that's sort of a
reckless attitude
the Lord has people all over the place
that are walking in the light that they
have and we need to respect them as
children of God especially don't forbid
them we can end up doing the work of the
devil like that you know there was one
of the problems that the Pharisees had
in the time of Christ where they thought
they were the only ones that
a saving type of attitude or
relationship when Jesus said many shall
come from the east and the west and
shall be seated with Abraham and the
children will be cast out so it's not
just what your denomination affiliation
is it's whether or not you know the Lord
yeah like Christ when his first sermon
in Nazareth said there were many lepers
in the land in the days of Elijah but
only the Syrian was healed and there
were many widows in the days of Elijah
and he went to a Canaanite Widow so
Christ is saying I've got people that
I'm listening to their prayers in other
countries other lands other backgrounds
and and they're looking for God
absolutely thanks appreciate your
question and that was Moses I think
we're gonna go next and do we have time
for one more oh no we don't have time
for one our engineer told us we're gonna
take a break in just a minute we don't
want to cut you off in after 40 seconds
hey don't go anywhere before the break I
just want to remind you that amazing
facts has just doodles and scads and
gobs of information Bible studies videos
books and resources at our website it's
so easy to remember it's just amazing
facts not o RG you just type in amazing
facts at Google or Yahoo some search
engine it'll take you to the ministry
page and you can watch and listen to
your heart's delight lots of free
material there as well as others
don't go anywhere friends we're going to
be back in just a moment with more Bible
questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
we know we're here but we're not here
for very long so the most important
thing would be if we could learn during
this life how to live forever this is
the central focus of amazing facts I
think it's very important for us to
build churches but if the churches lose
the message of salvation they just
become buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
Friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven may God bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 for seven once again that's
808 three five six seven four seven now
let's join pastors doug batchelor
and Jean Ross for more Bible answers
live hello listening friends we are back
in if you've tuned in along the way this
is Bible answers live and we are gonna
get right to the phones my name is Doug
Batchelor
my name is John Ross and we have George
listening from Illinois George welcome
to the program hi thanks for calling we
can and your question comment I kept the
status for a lot of years and then I
quit keeping it because I kind of come
to the prison it is for the Gentiles
only but there was no Sabbath given as
law until one just went to the mountain
can I respectfully disagree and I'll
show you a verse in the Bible okay
the question is did the Sabbath exist
before
I went to Mount Sinai well I can in the
story of Moses first of all when he goes
to Pharaoh when he first meets with
Pharaoh he meets for the elders of
Israel before he talks to Pharaoh he
tells about how God is led them and
ostensibly he mentions the Sabbath
because Pharaoh then says to Moses I'm
not going to give the people grass
anymore for the bricks because you are
causing them to the Hebrew word is you
are causing them to rest
it's Sabbath you're causing them to
Sabbath and then you go to Exodus 16 and
before they ever get to Mount Sinai
God says I will rain bread down from
heaven six days a week
gather a little extra on Friday so there
are the sixth day so that you have some
for the Sabbath when they didn't listen
to Moses God said how long will you
refuse to keep my laws well God has not
gotten to Mount Sinai yet that's Exodus
20 he's already calling the Sabbath the
law and then of course you've got where
Jesus said the Sabbath was made for man
that were theirs on through pulse it
means mankind that's back in Genesis 2
in the Garden of Eden where God blessed
the Sabbath day and he rested that day
obviously something he wanted man to do
that was replaced in before Moses went
to the mountain was there a place where
God says I command you to keep the
Sabbath yes Exodus 16 I know that story
in regards to and I'm assuming that was
just a factor with God dead and it
established a seven-day week so I don't
see the world I command now everybody in
the world all the people Sabbath well
what about you know do you think the Ten
Commandments were just for the Jews well
that's the way I've kind of come to the
conclusion because the jackdaw nation
ever said in your long well can you name
any of the other Ten Commandments that
it's okay for a Gentile to break can a
Gentile worship idols are we supposed to
worship idols the second descendant no
had command covers seven has all seven
of the same wall in the Ten Commandments
but the Jews they went to the mountain
on when Israel or Moses with the
mountain there was three month to the
seven for the Israel only the dead talk
with Gentile
in since the beginning remember the
seven Noahide laws do not murder do not
steal you know I don't know what clause
that was all there establish didn't book
a demon there's a commandment that says
don't take the name of the Lord in vain
right now you probably agree a Christian
I'm assuming you agree Christians should
keep that alright can you show me that
commandment in the New Testament yeah
I'm just saying that's one of the Ten
Commandments but you only find it in the
in the Old Testaments but you know that
Christians are supposed to keep that so
my point is and I appreciate your good
spirit my point is George that you would
probably agree that we should keep all
nine of the ten command it's it's except
the Sabbath I know you believe we should
honor father and mother that we should
not take God's name in vain we should
not worship idols john repeats that in
the new testament keep yourself from
idols the only commandment you seem to
have a problem with is the fourth
commandment the longest of the ten it's
in the middle of the law and it's the
only one that begins with the word
remember probably because God knew that
people would forget it says I remember
that it seems like God was talking to
Israel and well now you and I are saved
under the New Covenant right God says
salvation comes from him alone that's
what I believe well yeah well I think we
all agree with that the Jew and Gentile
but my question is that as a Gentile
we're saved by the New Covenant right
but the point is the Sabbath law I was
trying arrow down is the first time I
know the rule not to pick up man out on
that on Friday
you know insanity I know the rules are
but for any time I've seen where it says
all right command my Communion I command
that pertains implement do you think
there's any reason that a Christian
wouldn't want to keep the Ten
Commandments not the majority I'm yes
you know you don't want to murder you
don't want to steal because they were
all there seven Noahide commandments
because God wanted to have
in order in the beginning because it's
just a common man that was no dude in
the beginning but the first 2500 years
those new Israelites are no Jews per se
you know when God blesses the Sabbath in
Genesis when there's only Adam and Eve
in the world did he expect man to treat
it as a blessed day well in the Jewish
dictionary they kind of look at the word
safe and holy means it is finished it
didn't say I command you to people all
the rest of the world they didn't even
know it existed they ain't know they
have TV in the world yeah all right well
you know I'd be happy to send you we
have a study that talks about that and
as our friends listening have heard us
talk before we we believe that
Christians should be keeping all Ten
Commandments that they're it's not a ten
percent discount we have a book that
talks about written in stone it's a
special study guide if you'd like a free
copy we'd love to give you on George and
hope you take a look it's entitled a
lost day in history and you'll find it
very interesting a lot of good Bible
verses there and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and you're gonna answer the study guide
called the last day in history if you
have a Bible question a phone line is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven in six days God created the
heavens and the earth for thousands of
years man has worshiped God on the
seventh day of the week now each week
millions of people worship on the first
day
what happened why did God create a day
of rest does it really matter what day
we worship who's behind this great shift
discover the truth behind God's law and
how it was changed visit Sabbath truth
calm
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com
Omar is calling from Jamaica Omar
welcome to the program good night pastor
Doug and prosperous evening well my
question to you is does God sends us
trials
if not then oh well the Bible tells us
in the book of James that God temps no
man neither can he be tempted with evil
when the devil came to the Lord he
wanted to test job God needed to allow
or give the devil the permission to do
that
every good and perfect gift comes from
God it's the devil that often temps
harasses and a noise but God may allow
trials to come to us God doesn't tempt
us God is not you know I just heard
about the police they captured these
guys that were smuggling drugs at the
airport but the FBI created a whole
thing of phony drugs so they would think
they were smuggling drugs they actually
weren't smuggling drugs some people call
that entrapment it means you set them up
to see if they'll take the bait
God does not use entrapment to say well
look I'm gonna tempt them to fall then
I'm gonna punish them if they do because
it's almost like you become an
accomplice to the evil so God does not
want us to fall he doesn't want us to
sin but sometimes he will allow
especially for not trusting in him he'll
allow the devil to come to us with
trials and you remember let me give you
an example Paul and pastor Ross might
look this up for me where Paul talks but
the thorn in his side Paul says that
there was a messenger from Satan that
came to buff at him Paul tells us where
it comes from
then Paul prays to God to take away this
thorn in his side God says my strength
is made perfect in weakness so God is
clearly allowing the trial but Paul says
the trial is coming from the devil see
what I'm saying
gotcha I have a I have a chapter where I
wanted to share with you see it's in the
first time it was 16 verse 14
which is what the Spirit of the Lord
departed from salt and an evil spirit
from the Lord trouble him so that's not
a child that's like a test or something
God provided true the divide sure and
you explained that one coming
yeah let me give you another way to look
at that Saul grieved away God gave the
gift of the Spirit to Saul Saul grieved
away the Holy Spirit and it's like when
when you reject the light
what automatically comes when you push
the light out darkness and as Saul
pushed away the Spirit of the Lord then
an evil spirit came in and filled the
vacuum so when it says the spirit came
from the Lord it just means that when
the Lord withdrew he allowed then an
evil spirit to come in Christ talks
about a man in the New Testament who had
an evil spirit cast out but he doesn't
replace it with anything good and
there's a vacuum and the evil spirit
goes and gets six other friends and they
come back in because it hasn't been
replaced with anything good so you get
the same principle yes yes yes got it so
does that make sense yes well thank you
Omar we sure appreciate your question on
this and trying to think of we have a
booklet that talks about that we do have
a book called determining the will of
God yes sometimes people face trials and
they and they wonder why are these
things happening I think you'll enjoy
reading the book called determining the
will of God the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can just ask for the book
again it's called determining the will
of God
we've got AJ listening in Nebraska AJ
welcome to the program thank you hi and
your question tonight as Romans 14:20 it
says do not destroy the work of God for
the sake of food all food is clean but
it is wrong for a person to eat anything
that causes someone else to stumble but
first he says that some foods aren't
clean and then he says all foods are
clean and also how can you eat something
someone else to stumble good question
that how old are you 10 oh I'm so
thankful that you called you know pastor
Ross and I are getting ready to do a new
program next month for kids aged from 8
to 12 so you would really enjoy that
it's a new amazing adventure program but
let me answer your question real quick
when God says all things are pure our
Paul is speaking here he's not saying
that you can eat anything because just
think about that
there's things outside on the ground you
know God doesn't want you eating
cockroaches and skunks right I mean
there's just things that you know are
not clean so you have to ask yourself
wouldn't it be ridiculous to say that
God is saying you can eat anything
your mom will not let you eat anything
will she you can tell your mom you're
gonna have ice cream for breakfast no
she'd say that it may give you a sugar
rush she won't let you do that when Paul
says that all things are pure he's
talking specifically to a group that
were afraid to buy food from a market
and that the market was dedicated to
some Roman God like Jupiter Apollo and
Mercury Paul said look if you don't
sacrifice to these gods and you buy
something in their market it's all okay
you can eat that food he's talking about
clean foods Paul is not he's not talking
about anything can be eaten there he's
talking about when they were arguing
about things offered to idols yeah yeah
you know Bible says whatever you eat
whatever you drink and do it to the
glory of God that means it's possible to
not eat and drink to his glory so God
wants us to care for our bodies because
our bodies are the temple of the holy
spirit and the bottle is pretty clear he
doesn't want us to use drugs and drink
alcohol so we know there's some things
you should not put in your mouth yeah
hey thank you very much AJ does that
help answer your question yeah no all
right he thank you we hope you can tune
into our amazing adventure program for
life-changing Christian resources visit
AF bookstore com or call one eight
hundred five three eight seven two seven
five
next close we have a Samantha listening
from Kentucky Samantha welcome to the
program thank you how are you doing this
evening doing well thank you for calling
thank you for having me so my issue is
that and I want to say that I've been a
listener for many years and very much
admire the work that you're doing thank
you so much my issue is that a friend of
mine recently posed a question to me and
I've been struggling with this I've been
studying it and it's on the percentage
of the Holy Spirit
my friend posed the issue that the
Trinity is not necessarily a Trinity
whether it's specifically the father and
the son and that the Holy Spirit is more
or less just a manifestation of the mind
of the two of them can you clarify this
for me and I also want to point out John
14 I'm starting with verse 16 and going
on to about 18 I guess and it's talking
here you know Christ is saying that he's
talking about the father sending the
comforter
referred to as the Spirit of Truth and
then he goes on to say I will not leave
you alone I will come to you so this
kind of lends to that train of thought I
just wanted some clarification okay good
question
so first of all is the Holy Spirit a
unique individual
you know Jesus makes a number of
statements where he says in for example
in John chapter 14 verse 26 when the
helper comes who I will send you from
the father the Spirit of Truth which
proceeds from the father he will testify
of me John 16:13 however when he the
spirit of truth comes he will guide you
into all truth he will not speak on his
own authority but whatever he hears he
will speak and he will tell you of
things to come you can read him out
where it tells us the Holy Spirit was
grieved a matter of fact as you look at
the different characteristics of the
Holy Spirit you find in the Bible the
Holy Spirit can be grieved the Holy
Spirit is there in Genesis he's all the
way in revelation
I'll give you a few verses I'm gonna put
your voice on hold Samantha cuz we're
getting feedback I don't know if you
have the radio want hopefully you're
still able to hear me and I'm going to
come back to you in just a moment if you
look for example in let's see here you
can look in Luke chapter 3 verse 21 when
all when Jesus was baptized the father
said this is my beloved son Jesus came
out of the water
Holy Spirit descended in bodily form in
Romans 7 that says for the kingdom of
God is not eating and drinking but
righteousness peace and joy in the holy
spirit for whom serves Christ in these
things so here in this one verse you've
got God Holy Spirit Christ in 2nd
Corinthians 1:21 now he who establishes
us with you is Christ and he's anointed
us in God who has sealed us with the
Holy Spirit I've got about 20 verses
here that mentioned father son and
spirit separately even the first part of
Revelation chapter 1 verse 4 John to the
seven churches who are in Asia Grace and
peace to him who is and who was and who
is to come and from the seven spirits
that are before his throne and from
Jesus Christ here in the benediction you
got father son spirit all mentioned I
don't have time actually to go through
all these verses
Samantha putting you back on now I've
got a book I'm here at a little feedback
here I've got a book on the Trinity that
we'll be happy to send you a free copy
I just recently wrote talks about the
Holy Spirit and the book is called the
Trinity is a biblical and we'll be happy
to send this to you Samantha why anybody
wanted to learn more about this
important topic the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called the Trinity is it
biblical we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks yeah hope that
helps it is a difficult subject but I've
done a lot of study on it I'm convinced
the Holy Spirit is a unique person
separate from the father and son next
caller that we have is Aaron listening
in Nashville Tennessee Aaron welcome to
the program
hey you hearing me loud and clear
okay great and your question tonight
question is in the book of Genesis you
find where God created Adam he said it
is not good for man to be he know when
he created Adam he said that it is not
good for Adam to be a man to be alone
let us give him a help me and you know
the story how a story goes he made Eve
Adam has his wife right and he the fruit
when God told him not to the data sheets
of tissue you shall surely die for
though she warned oh she shall return
and she brought the fruit to Adam and
when Adam I believe tell me if I'm wrong
because of the love for his wife chose
to die with her her chose to go along
with this idea I've always said that
isn't it the same with Christ because
Adam was willing to die was willing to
give up everything eternal life
everything that God gave him for his
wife and Christ did the very same thing
he laid aside everything for the bride
which is the church Israel that's a good
analogy in that it is true that Christ
gave himself for the church the problem
that you've got with Adam Adam loves you
so much he put Eve above God and he
sinned against God rather than be
separated from her now it is true that
love Jesus loves the church desperately
and was willing to die to redeem the
church but not if it required him to sin
us because he lived a sinful iced life
to save her so that's where you know
probably the analogy might break down a
little bit but doesn't it contradicts
the verse that when it says that there's
no greater love that for one foot to lay
down his life for a friend and you've
clearly seek and see that Adam was
willing to lay down his life for his
wife was going to give up everything for
his life so isn't that a type of godly
love that he had for his wife not
questioning how much he loved Eve but
you shouldn't love the gift more
than the giver and he ended up loving
Eve more than the one who gave him Eve
you know the commandments are
summarizing in the two great
Commandments the first is to love God
with all your heart soul in mind
secondly to love your neighbor as
yourself
and so yes we ought to love others as we
love ourselves but our first devotion
and obedience is to be to our Heavenly
Father absolutely
hey thank you Aaron we sure appreciate
your call tonight we're gonna try and
squeeze in a couple more questions while
we got time let's see we've got let's go
to Manny listening from New York Manny
welcome to the program good evening
Panthers evenin thank you for your
question and your home so I'm calling
because I have a little concern here I
do believe that Mystery Babylon is
definitely as far as prophecy is
definitely wrong
but I have a little concern you know
revelation 11:8 it says and their dead
bodies shall lie in the street of the
great city which spiritually is called
Sodom and Egypt where also our Lord was
crucified so that kind of makes me it's
kind of a little confusing because um if
Mystery Babylon is wrong why here does
it says that the Lord saw Jesus was
crucified on on basically Jerusalem well
I keep in mind and I forget the verse
pastor Ross is at Hebrews where it says
crucifying the Son of God Hebrews 10
crucifying the Son of God afresh some
when it talks in revelation about
crucifying Jesus it doesn't mean just
the one time he was crucified in
Jerusalem every time we are persecuted
Christ says in the money and as much as
you do it to the least of these you do
it to me and there's many times that the
Lord has spiritually been crucified
again in the way that his people have
been persecuted revelation 11 is talking
about this persecution of the two
witnesses in the city which is
spiritually called Sodom and Egypt many
believe this is this was talking about
the birth of atheism in France during
the French
and that's just there a few weeks ago no
the Bible was outlawed they burned
Bibles in the street you know the two
witnesses or the Word of God the law and
the prophets and knew in the Old
Testament and it was under attack during
that time so it means they're
spiritually called Sodom and Egypt but
yeah of course Jesus was crucified in
Jerusalem or just outside the city when
people attack the followers of the Lord
and the truth or attacking Jesus right
so it's not safe to call Jerusalem
Mystery Babylon or just but there's many
Babylon
well you know there's the you got the
ancient literal Babel and then you got
spiritual Babel and that Peter refers to
and they were talking about Rome at that
time and Peter was crucified in Rome and
Paul was beheaded there so it was a
place of persecution but this particular
prophecy in revelation 11 is talking
about as the gospel move from east to
west and it'd be you know there's a big
revival in france during the time of
Calvin and the Reformation but then
there was a big war against Christianity
there and Protestantism and finally the
country turned to atheism France was
probably one of the first atheist
Ignatians well definitely in Europe
maybe the first in the world and it's
still extremely secular to there today I
was just there very hard to do
evangelism in France and when you notice
it talks about spiritually Egypt you
remember when the Pharaoh said to Moses
who is the Lord I don't know the Lord
I'm not gonna let Israel go and solemn I
don't have to detail why Sodom was
immoral people that have been to Paris
know that it's a very sensual City and
they're not at all ashamed to talk about
personal things in public and during the
time of the French Revolution all the
leaders in Europe had their wives and
then they had their girlfriends and it
was extremely loose just write a book
about John Adams in Paris and he
couldn't believe their behavior many I
don't know I think we run out of time we
have
we appreciate if we didn't get all of
your questions here we have a study
guide that talks about French Revolution
we got the book called two witnesses
well they're you know probably addresses
every verse and again will
able to send to anyone who calls and ask
the numbers 883 five six seven four
seven asked for the book called the two
witnesses a thank you listening friends
before we go to some of our closing
announcements I just want to remind you
that we're only here where you hear us
right now because people like you say
hey we're blessed and they go online and
they click to keep us on the air hope
you can do it
god bless talk to you next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Corrine was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Corrine to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Corrine has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend
have an opportunity to help someone
today and to make an eternal difference
for more people like Corrine you're a
simple investment of faith and amazing
facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one we're just visit give dot amazing
facts dot o-r-g or send your gift to
peel box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight thank you for studying the
Word of God with me today and I hope
that you plan now to join me again next
week as we discover more amazing facts
word of god did you know that Noah was
present at the birth of Abraham okay
maybe he wasn't in the room but he was
alive and probably telling stories about
his floating zoo from the creation of
the world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History com4
life-changing Christian resources visit
AF bookstore calm or call one eight
hundred five three eight seven two
seventy-five if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word
visit our website at
www.lazyguycooking.com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
you